et c'est le top 20 que vous attendez
comme tous les soirs votre top 20
spéciales fou rire aujourd'hui j'ai dû
très très très très lourd c'est vrai que
l'on a eu des fous rires dans des ppp
dans d'autres émissions notamment et
castaldi est bénigne et là ce soir on
commence notre top 20 avec
c'est mon choix c'est evelyne thomas qui
recevait des gens qui ont des rires de
ouf
et forcément quand l'un qui commence à
rigoler les autres suivent vous allez
voir tout le monde est mort de rien ça
c'est le top 20 de notre top fous rires
c'est parti regardez numéro 20 ses
arrières d'asthmatiques c'est à dire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça c'est magique c'est parti et ses
parties de 2 partout alors vous vous
demandez où et matthieu delormeau
matthieu delormeau est en train de
recharger son téléphone passé voilà il
n'a plus de batterie avec voilà avec
l'application en 19e position
c'est une image qu'on voit rarement
c'est les humoristes qui se tape un fou
rire alors qu'ils sont sur scène la cité
en 96
c'est muriel robin notre mur robin qu'on
embrasse elle est dans son spectacle
robin et ça c'est une image qui a été vu
très très rarement mais énorme
elle est dix neuvième de notre
classement des fous rires regarde je
suis là maintenant
côté mâles
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
donc on vise à valoriser des jo
c'est pas pour rien et les gens et le
public adore ça mine de rien c'est vrai
qu'on ira fou rire comme ça quand on
oublie le texte c'est exceptionnel et on
va revenir en 18e position si vous êtes
là sachez que c'est le top 20 fous rires
ce soir qu'on vous propose dans ce soir
chez ba ba en direct réunissez toute la
famille est là en 18e position
c'est un fou rire qui nous concerne
c'était il ya quelques années dans tpm p
je pense que je vous dis c'est un des
plus grands fous rires également que
j'ai eues on avait eu le fisc allié avec
camille combal le fils caché de gilles
verdez et isabelle morini bosc et
franchement il y avait julien courbet
que j'embrasse aussi mais on était tous
mordret quand on va voir ça en cuir on a
quand même envie de retourner en plateau
mais c'est pas pour tout de suite
regardé une danse endiablée agile et
apparemment ils ont commis l'irréparable
on a retrouvé la photo de leur fille on
l'a la regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
elle a prêté le côté ayant fait des
[Applaudissements]
photos soyez pas du diazépam usa bcs est
exceptionnel ça franchement c'est qu'il
ya des promos srx et en faisant glisser
ces fous rires en plateau on a hâte
on a hâte de revenir en plateau série
qu'on en a pleuré mais vraiment quand je
vous dis pleurer c'est pleurer ça
c'était exceptionnel et gilles verdez et
isabelle morini bosc qui prennent
toujours bien les choses
bravo il s'appelle tu reviendras nature
quand on sera en plateau à isabelle les
shihri en 17e position des fous rires
c'est dans la version portugaise du
juste prix en place essentielle temps où
je t'offre l'autre on sait pas pourquoi
mais une candidate s'est mise à avoir un
fou rire de dengue et les têtes sont
folles regardez bien les têtes dans le
juste prix portugais laon dix septième
position c'est du très très lourd
regarder
eh ouais et là on vous dit aller dans
toutes les émissions si zabel
morini-bosc installé par mon corps tugal
elle entend aller partout et elles
trustent le paf du chantier quoi c'est
un truc de fou quoi les têtes sont
magnifiques mois gg je vous jure que
c'est vrai j'ai une tendresse pour les
portugais
ils sont tous je trouve qu'ils sont
hyper sympathique gg en plus je vous lis
le premier gros tournages que j'ai fait
je les fais au portugal je m'en rappelle
j'avais fait une publicité qui devait se
tourner à lisbonne qui était pour
bouygues telecom et le réalisateur kim
avait choisi au casting je peux vous
dire c'était michel hazanavicius rend
des comptes au café un oss 117 et
artistes ou ça j'avais passé un casting
et il m'avait choisi j'étais comme un
fou alors avancé c'était déjà un grand
réalisateur puisqu'il avait réalisé les
nuls et c'est lui qui avait donc réalisé
la pub donc le portugal pour moi ça
reste un souvenir exceptionnel
d'ailleurs dans les âmes en parlant des
nuls dans un instant il y aura les
inconnus sur ces huit ans donc oui
soirée spéciale des inconnus ça ça va
cartonner en 16e position
c'est pendant les jo de rio hier hervé
mathoux que j'embrasse fort qui est un
mec génial aussi que j'aime beaucoup et
laurie delhostal ils ont commenté la
victoire d'une cycliste allemande qui a
terminé sa course sans sel
hervé mathoux posture à la journaliste
laure il est bien entendu hervé vous le
connaissez il peut vite partir en fou
rire parce que hervé il est sérieux mais
c'est le mec en classe us et hervé si tu
la connais toi tu sais qui va suivre
dans tous tes délires regarde
l'essentiel
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et qu'est-ce qui se passe tdr on est
troublé par cette nouvelle on fait le
bilan peut-être l'équipe de france c'est
un peu décevant pour l'instant oui une
effectivement une seule médaille hier
pour l'instant pour l'équipe de france
en bronze avec la vitesse par équipes
l'équipe de france qui avait remporté
quatre médailles aux jeux olympiques de
londres alors pour vous laisser le temps
de former hervé on va écouter le bilan
du président de la fédération française
de cyclisme david lappartient
je vous le dis quand il est parti hervé
et laurie allait super aussi les deux
rires j'aime énormément et font partie
d'un groupe de canal est vraiment c'est
pas parce qu'ils font à canal que je les
aime beaucoup vraiment hervé c'est un
super mec voilà je le dis il faut
toujours le jeu et laurie aussi elle est
super sympa donc bravo à eux et je
comprends le fou rire vacances à part
ces morts 1 c'est terminé on va passer
en 15e position rentrer dans le top 15
des fous rires et je sais que ça vous
plaît énormément de réactions sur
twitter vous êtes toute la famille en
train de nous regarder on parle chez nos
amis belges que j'embrasse fort sur la
rtbf il ya un mec qui est venu sur le
plateau de l'émission pour parler des
moules forcément évidemment rien mais
qui vient pour parler de moules en
plateau ça peut que partir en fou rire
est forcément et ce qu'arrive regarde ce
soit on voit passer à table il baer nous
emmener à la pêche aux moules carrément
ni plus ni moins sébastien oui depuis
que l'homme existe il s'est toujours
intéressé à l'amour hommes
préhistoriques manger déjà des moules
d'ailleurs ce sont les hollandais ont
inventé cette culture de la moule qui
s'appelle amis tlic
mois on prétend qu'on peut manger des
moules uniquement les mois en r la
saison nous commencerons juillet et se
termine et donc son laiteuse elles sont
au gars sont en phase de production et
de manière générale c'est un régal
on doit d'ailleurs envoûté on en est aux
côtés le mec le mec qui la pousse je
suis il affectait et ça ça qu'on voit un
bon chroniqueur il savait que ça allait
partir vois pas ce que tu dirais qui tu
démarres direct sa chronique
de tout temps les hommes se sont
intéressés aux moules là c'est vraiment
adoré les moules il savait que ça allait
partir fort très fort et bravo à nos
amis belges ça j'adorais mais ça on le
sent arriver on sait que ça va être un
fou rire c'est sûr et certain
les cherry en 14e position des fous
rires ça s'est passé dans l'amour est
dans le pré c'est en 2018 ya christophe
un agriculteur qui demande à sa
prétendante si elle se rase et la foire
sa part en cacahuète total je regardais
l'amour est dans le pré 14e de nos fous
rires regarder ça j'ai toujours barber 4
5 jours tu tombes en fait ouais
toi tu traces non je m'épile vraiment
intelligent je m'épile je ne me rase pas
bien combiner le meilleur de ce fou rire
c'est le sait bien franchement c'est
d'abord avoir un fou rire comme ça avec
un mec c'est génial franchement ça ça
déjà il a marre il a marqué des points
le mec on voit quelle complicité je sais
que benhaim adore rire mais naim et vous
en dis ne dit on pas femme qui rit à
moitié dans son lit mais je peux vous
dire quand vous avez déjà deux moitiés
benhaim vous êtes déjà très bien très
content alors maintenant nous a déjà
très très content en 13e position on
retrouve encore hervé mathoux et cette
fois ci il est dans le canal football
club et le fou rire vient de pierre
ménès notre pierrot que j'ai eue
aujourd'hui par sms et il se remet mon
père ou lembras fort il critique un
joueur sauf que le joueur en question
n'a jamais joué c'est à dire que pire
aux idées font un joueur mais le joueur
n'a pas joué c'est pour ça c'est pour ça
aussi que j'aime qui armé nes et vous
allez voir que pierre les laisse se
démonte pas regardé
germa parce que je veux bien qu'il ait
pas beaucoup de ballons c'est pas facile
de le trouver non plus et s'engager
parce que je n'ai pas vu d'accord merci
à tous merci aux équipes quittent et à
toulouse ce soir stéphane massé les
grands aussi cinq secondes ses fans pour
un jeu des plus jeunes je pense que
pierre voulait parler de sanogo parce
que ce hangar n était pas sur la feuille
de match donc c'est sanogo sans doute
que hier n'a pas trouvé tard il l'a pas
vu effectivement c'est confirmé
jb c'est bien heureusement hervé mathoux
demande aussi aux gantois qui vont bien
un joueur il a dit je n'ai pas vu mais
le joueur là bas il n'a pas joué c'est
génial permet des champions du monde là
dessus quand ben bravo pirro on va
passer en 12e position est ce que vous
savez chez vous est ce que vous savez ce
qu'est la palourde de loi royal la
palourde royale
eh bien je vais vous dire dans
l'émission québécoise des kiwis et des
hommes
il est découvert qu'elle avait une forme
un très très bizarre c'est notre
compteur tous des fous rires
très drôle ça et vous allez-vous
souvenirs chez vous de la palourde
royale regarde jamais vu de panneaux
royal de ma vie
on fait face et viennent vider
[Rires]
ok ok on sait les saisir la vie on vous
pose des images qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
vu un qu'on a rarement vu vous n'avez
vous pas franchement c'est la dot héros
xii j'aimerais qu'on la revoie cela
parce que le mec qui la sort en fait le
mec s'attend pas du tout à ça et je vais
sentir la palourde royale et que nous
rigoler sur garros l'arbois ça la
regarde et il joue bien j'ai jamais vu
de panneaux royal de ma vie c est ce qu
on fait face et vient l'idée
[Rires]
ok ok on sait les saisir et allons-y
mais le mec il y croyait tellement à
saint palais royal puis la bis ou d'un
chiffon et aller ou pas il a juste eu un
motif il la sortie on dirait qu'ils
sortaient le nouvel iphone sans rigoler
s'approche de fou c'est génial merci
d'être avec nous tout cas au dépôt
direct on vous fait le top 20 des fous
rires et on est en 11e position
cette vidéo on aurait pu la placer dans
le top des jt mais nan c'est une
journaliste qui parle des personnes
centenaire
sauf qu'en image d'illustration le mec
en régie ils ont mis ma vie sans dents
avec un bonnet de noël et la pauvre elle
peut pas se retenir de rire parce
qu'elle voit l'image qu'ils ont misé
pour illustrer donc les centenaires et
là ça part en fou rire celle ci je
l'adorent aussi regarder c'est très très
fort ce top 11
clin d'oeil à hélène léonie et deux
d'entre elles aiment tenté trois
centenaires
excusez moi si j'avais mon enfant donc
tout est toutes les trois centres son
centenaire elle une belle fête son
anniversaire aujourd'hui jour de noël de
la maison de repos à blegny près de
liège vincent jamoulle et le fait qu'il
a toujours rencontré
séoul avait beaucoup elle est géniale de
sala rossa relate pas on va rentrer
maintenant dans le top 10 je vous dis
les fous rires
le classement des fous rires les plus
grands fous rires alors celui-là je les
adore parce qu'on comprend pas d'où il
part c'est dans attention à la marche
il ya je vous le dis il tape une barre
de rire de fou avec jean luc reichmann
parce qu'il a demandé un candidat ce qui
faisait dans la vie et le mec alors on
s'attend un truc de fou et en fait il
est juste moniteur d'auto-école rien ouf
mais bon ça parents fous rires regarder
il très drôle c'est du meyronnis
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en fait dominique il était tellement
heureux d'être là qui rigolaient à
chaque fois que jean luc reichmann lui
poser une question donc il était mort de
rire toute l'émission ça c'était un très
très grand moment et l'agent lui voilà
il aura joué dans ajouté c'est ça qu'on
aime
alors on est en 9e position en neuvième
position s'est passé encore dans tpm
paix et si celui-là qui avant tête où
j'étais mort de rire avec julien courbet
c'est sur le sosie d'edouard balladur
celui-là numéro 9 je pense que je suis
là c'est dans le top 3 des plus gros fou
rire qu'on a eu
voilà je vous le dis regardez et julien
courbet que je ne peux pas regarder qui
pleure de rire regarder avec camille et
moi regarde je me désole pas du tout ça
quand il ya des chiffres et des autres
j'aime assez cette semaine tant ben
ouais non super papy on ressemblait dans
balladur c'est pas beau il s'agit d'un
balayeur bomba a pas de tension
[Applaudissements]
prochaine ressemblent à des julia je ne
pouvais pas le regarder tu y as kobe
c'était magique ça l'égérie on va passer
en huitième position
une chaîne sur laquelle on s'en viennent
c'est une chaîne ou à laquelle on
s'intéresse peu c'est rfo à l'époque la
journaliste parlait d'un secrétaire
d'état
le mec s'appelle miam miam c'est que
lorsqu'un état s'appelle bien l'info via
dort plus
regarde les sous traitants et le
secrétaire d'état rappelle miam miam
et là forcément sa part en cacahuète
regarder ces numéros 8 des fous rires
sont peu plus ce soir garde qui est mia
mia le secrétaire d'état à l'intégration
estime que ce référendum est un échec à
la citoyenneté voilà on bâtit au score
avec 2 0 aux commandes je suis allé un
peu normal j'espère que nous allons
remettre ça nous en parler athlétisme et
avec le rideau catherine et cet après
midi sur le champion de france
d'athlétisme à narbonne avec un seul
record de france
vous vous en voir le résumé de cette
journée
[Rires]
en fait beau lck d'avoir un fou rire
elle tous étaient elles prennent tous
avant vrai vu valérie ou pas c'est
exceptionnel c'est numéro 8 des fous
rires et proche de sa vérité peut être
accordée alors en numéro 7 c'est un des
fous rires cultes de la télé c'est
pendant la promo du film le boulet que
j'adore d'ailleurs arnaud variés et
benoît poelvoorde
les mecs sont mort de rire du début à la
fin et la pauvre journaliste elle
n'arrive pas à faire son interview ça
c'est exceptionnel
aussi ces numéros 7 des fous rires merci
d'être avec nous en direct regarde entre
deux souches et donc on disait ce film
c'est une comédie d'action alors elle
repose sur un duo d'acteurs vous avez
vous êtes reparti dans des références
j'espère comme la chèvre les compères
des références qu'on connaît tous soyez
bien sûr c'est c'est c'est une volonté
absolue de notre part de faire des films
ce jour entre excusez moi parce que ça
cinq ans en se servant de ses références
qui sont pour nous l'essentiel est quand
vous avez accepté les rôles vous saviez
que ce serait avec ce partenaire là non
je ne savais pas
d'où ma double aujourd'hui
non je ne fais que ça non pas terrible
terrible et c'est probablement voyez
dans quel état je me trouve aujourd'hui
après un an de rapport très intime
on reprenait saucisses et il va
peut-être me après une tradition oui
c'est le retour au toril
c'est le retour du genre populaire alors
je vous racontais un truc en fait
pourquoi ils rigolent les deux c'est
parce que voilà quand ils sont allés
faire cette télé ils auront offert des
sushis devront servir des sushis en fait
peut il garder un petit peu fort ils ont
fait toute la tournée est il arrivé
commence à monter un souci et les sushis
sont horribles dégueulasse et elle
relance la machine en fait les
journalistes en disant bar prenez un
petit sushi sushi et là c'est reparti
c'est mort ça y est alors quand elle a
redit souci c'était c'était dingue allez
numéro 6 maintenant c'est dans les
maternelles sur france 5 daphné bürki
animé à l'époque les maternelles ils ont
un sujet sur un mec qui s'est fait
greffer un orteil à la place de son
pouce comme ça commence mal tout le
monde part en fou rire en se posant des
questions improbable le mec c'est
vraiment un greffé un orteil à la place
de garde
numéro 2 donc j'ai les contractions tous
al'excuse qui passe à peu près je ne
peux pas j'ai un pote qui à un orteil à
la place du pouce et il a besoin que je
lui tienne la main et c'est encore une
fois une bonne excuse car c'est vrai
première opération du genre tu es burns
s'est sectionné le pouce de la main
gauche au travail et bien le plombier de
29 ans s'est réveillé que composante à
gauche à la place de son budget ou
frutschi c'est vrai lui a greffé sous
pousse à temps plein du pouce de la main
alors ça sort de cette année là
messieurs c'est parce qu'il a les pattes
du boulanger mais moi mais mine de rien
la question qu'on se posait sur ce
dossier vous aussi parce que au par là
c'est ton qu'un mec et s'est fait
agresser vrai effet un orteil à la place
du pouce moi franchement je préfèrerais
de rien à voir je vais vous dire la
vérité c'est horrible non mais
franchement tu peux pas sortir
tu peux pas dire mon mec c'est le mec à
l'orteil rapaces du pouce va dribbler
reprises la question ne veut pas ça veut
dire il s'est fait couper c'est pas son
orteil c'est un orteil d'un haut de
gamme non mais ça à la rupture
bah non il va pas se couper leur taille
ils enferment allant et d'alain pinson
orteils d'amis quoi bah oui c'est sûr
c'est un autre gars et une oreille mais
non c'est leur tête d'un autre gars
c'est sûr et certain
à mon avis c'est sûr je bois je crois
pas que soit leur année ça sert à rien
alors que vous savez a great chaude et
d'owendo et donc mais là le mec il a pas
d'orthez il à leur taille trop le primat
est le même quand il fait du stop on le
voit de loin dans le top 5 des fous
rires comment ne pas faire un top courir
sans celui le plus connu du monde
risi tu as quand il parle de son boulot
wraps et de saubens regardez regardez ça
fait 2 milliard de vues
c'est exceptionnel mais si le sourire
regarder et le rire garde sa chenil
d'euros 5 t partir hésitations sous n'a
pas brillé hier à l'euro
media markt en chine et en russie a fait
mais pas le bayer va élaborer la
traviata naquit mais le bagnard simple
terminal au départ
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on dira adopte un jet mettra le mec
c'est vous dire et ouvre le dauphin a
compté bien sûr j'aime bien ça c'était
du 05 ça fait m rendez compte que cette
vidéo elle a fait 2 milliard de vues
dans le monde
en numéro 4 c'est un fou rire que
j'adore parce qu'on rentre dans le top 4
des fous rires merci d'être avec nous et
en direct c'est celui de mon pote
omar sy et il est avec fred testot qui
balance une vanne sur raymond domenech
est là fred testot il voit qu'il a fait
un bide mais là omar parents fous rires
total regardez et personnes comprend
pourquoi mais omar il explique pourquoi
regarder avec la moustache c'est l'année
où il passait son bac il avait 19 ans
raymond domenech moustache qui est passé
sur les sourcils après
le fou rire communicatif
[Rires]
parce que ma il explique qu'après que
fred il a vu que sa balle elle était
passée un petit peu au travail il a
voulu là là là à faire voilà mais s'est
bien passé comme moi je trouvais ça très
drôle
les chiffons rentrer dans le top 3 ça y
est et en numéro 3 c'est un des plus
gros fous rires que j'ai eu à la
télévision c'est pendant le téléthon et
c'était en 89 et forcément les téléthons
ça dure longtemps et c'est une émission
exceptionnelle et c'est claude sérillon
qui présentait et il est avec michel
boujenah qui racontait ses problèmes de
son pays est petit à petit sa part en
fous rires je vous jure que ça je peux
le revoir mille fois et vous aussi
michel qui va mieux je crois qu'il va
mieux vaut michel m'envoies un petit sms
que j'embrasse fort et regarder michel
boujenah exceptionnel fantastique ces
numéros 3 je vous le disais tout à
l'heure l'ami michel boujenah est de
nous rejoindre c'est sympa michel est
passé comme ça ben je me disais je
rentrais de l'image où j'ai joué et je
me disais que c'était je me suis en fait
je suis déshabillé oui et donne tous les
détails
d'autant plus que moi j'ai j'ai été
assez malade quand j'étais petit j'étais
très malheureux
ça fait rire tout petit jeu sérieuses et
lunaire il ya un type un jour il m'a dit
mais à taux plein que j'ai dit mais si
je m'arrête me plaindre je gagne plus ma
vie plus je me plains plus les gens
ismar c'est extraordinaire maxime maxime
catherine sur le sort de promesses de
paris puis à prendre le train je crois
que jacques était déjà arrivée celle
boulba exceptionnel et quand il part au
pourrait empêcher le burkina c'est
fabuleux vraiment bravo michel qui est
numéro 2 et numéro 3 ce soir défaut on
va rentrer dans le top 2 maintenant et
on part en belgique et c'est jean
dujardin et gilles lellouche qui sont
venus faire la promo de leur film la
french et on sait pas pourquoi mais
gilles lellouche sera une expression en
anglais
et là ça part dans
pascal jean dujardin se dit mais
pourquoi il dit ça pourquoi il se la
raconte comme ça ces numéros de regarder
très très gros fou rire jean dujardin
gilles lellouche rien numéros déjà des
personnages pour des acteurs qui sont
absolument incroyable interpréter une
dimension conquis son bigger than life
donc c'est vraiment extraordinaire
toujours et puis on les a perdus
oui en temps dit arrêté parce que c'est
dommage mais c'est mathématique
et oui et ils sont entrés par les deux
oui là ils peur bigger than life essayé
mais pourquoi il a dit ça et on passe
numéro un note notre moment préféré
alors site en 2004 c'était sur le
plateau des 100 plus grands est ce que
ça vous dit quelque chose c'est avec
christophe dechavanne sur le plateau des
100 plus grands ir sauver et recevez
benoît poelvoorde et françois berléand
s'il y avait plus d'autres invités et
fut pris d'un fou rire de ouf
à cause de la vidéo de retrouvailles
qu'ils viennent de voir ça je ne m'en
lasse pas c'est très très fort
on a mis sa numéro 1 des fous rires
regarder régalez-vous sais pas
monsieur schmitt j'ai la joie de vous
présenter jeu certains le fils que vous
avez eue avec de vie
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est un médicament nécessaire
bon la barre de l'heure
qu'est ce que c'est que j'ai dit
[Applaudissements]
du miroir et les chéris comme tous les
soirs je demande à un chroniqueur celle
qu'il a préféré même suivant la classe
et cela durant valérie bénaïm que tu
veux revoir quoi sa médaille tu veux
revoir la palourde l écho que nous
rejoignent et veut revoir la palourde
royale s'était regardé la palourde
royale benhaim et coquine c'est pour ça
qu'on les regarde jamais vu de panneaux
royal de ma vie on fait face et vient
vider
[Rires]
ok ok on sait les saisir et alosi voilà
après c'était notre petit cadeau la
palme world watch